I just got out of a quiet place you have
to go see this movie just cancel your
plans stop what you're doing and go to
the movie theater
now that's an endorsement this is
relative but by the way America agrees
with you Chris the movie has a 97%
rating on Rotten Tomatoes it's got
pretty much everybody here at et buzzing
and it topped the box office this
weekend with 50 million bucks which is
the second-best opening of the year
domestically so Wow Doug alright and
Chris's axon appearance has a lot to say
as well and only we have it she is
sounding off about her life after Chris
and what she has learned about love my
mom always told me to be selfish in love
and I didn't understand what that meant
until I got a little older but I think
what she meant was I guess the idea of
valuing oneself especially as a woman
only a few months after their split
Donna tells Women's Health magazine she
and Chris worked hard to communicate
openly as they co-parent five-year-old
son Jack saying quote we reiterate that
there aren't rules to this we have a lot
of love and friendship and our big goal
is to protect Jack after the breakup
Anna was the first to find new love with
cinematographer Michael Barrett who she
met on the set of her upcoming movie
overboard saying quote I need a sense of
human connection and intimacy I want to
be with someone I can confess to and who
can't confess to me super fit at 41 on
us full of confessions that ultimate
guilty pleasure is an amazing bacon
cheeseburger and she's secure enough to
admit having breast augmentation 11
years ago she says as a staunch feminist
she still floored that she did it quote
I always thought plastic surgery was
caving in to the man she says but I
wanted to tell out a bikini
I kept thinking am i betraying my own
gender by doing this I spent like my 20s
feeling incredibly insecure but now I
don't anymore feeling good by the way
CBS also just renewed on a show mom for
a 6
thank congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]